yeah well these are all good
so it does have push to talk should we
try it is that the cool new trend in
gaming
yeah well i mean it's so obvious
[Music]
don't look at me statue man oh the
statue does move i 100 percent see what
you're saying
what the hell can you hear me in game
guys oh yeah
are we doing in game hang on hello
okay yo the voice says real stuttery for
you okay the end game voice is
not working it's awful that's horrible
you look just like ezekiel the third
mark
thank you i was thinking that i love
your shoulders thank you your shoulders
look 100
human anyway there's a piece of paper
here
mind looking for the box of tape
recorders while you're setting those
stupid ghosts up all right what are we
doing we're setting ghosts up
we've got more um more things over here
oh here's the thing
may survival guide a complete guide of
getting out of a maze and survival tips
for surviving
the maze i apparently took that into my
inventory
this note says generators shouldn't be
running this hard neither should our
computers
either johnny's got some more something
more hiding this maze or wiring's worse
than the damn hedge
hard for the course of johnny though
just charge him an arm and a leg and
move along so generators are having
issues apparently whatever that means
what is this dead by daylight oof hmm
okay i guess we go away well i guess we
enter yeah
all right oh look how fast look how fast
we move here
oh yeah you are quick
okay i already like the ambiance of this
not at all terrifying tree tunnel jeez
we don't have any lights right there's
no t or f no uh
no one it's so the control said one is
cycle lights and two is cycle items so
i'm assuming we're going to be gaining
things oh there's a flashlight over here
did we get the uh recorder over here
i did yes i can now play tapes
okay well good uh good good sonic
workflow
become a better game developer and enjoy
great game developer comedy
okay man it is dark in here
so you're saying we're gonna want the oh
my god it's dark yeah it gets dark
real quick oh [ __ ] what happened all the
electricity and lights over there
generators running too hard man
there's a light this seems like [ __ ]
what happened to you
it's fine oh i see oh my god yeah
go down there go down there come here
buddy
god damn it thanks man that's pretty
good yeah it got me
i don't did you not hear me just almost
throw my keyboard
i heard but i didn't know what it was
that got you because i was looking at a
sign i was reading a song
this way all right i trust this yeah
it's not helping me that i'm playing in
a house where other people are
upstairs and they're slamming around
right now
first fork oh wait nope
oh that's adorable it's just little
spooky spooks like that
nice so this away
everything's fine you're going that way
keep it up wow oh wow that's dark
okay yeah oh it's getting narrower looks
good [ __ ] god damn it
you saw a
i [ __ ] play scary games
wait this way or that way i don't know
man i don't know are we staying together
or are we splitting up
i don't think we should split up i think
that's a bad idea all right well then
let's go
let's take the first let's take it okay
okay
all right this one seems like this one
seems like you're meant to miss it
because it's real dark but then there's
a light
what was that that was did anyone else i
saw a shadow or something
i don't want to go this way you got it
man you got it man you got it wait
listen oh my god
that's that didn't scare me but the
ghost stick things are scaring me i
don't know
that one was more concerning less of a
jump scare yeah
yeah you guys just go first okay i don't
want to go this way
i don't want to go the other way no
that's fine i said this way the sign
said this way
maybe it was lying the sign said this
way oh my god guys
you can you can walk into the bush
you can walk into the bush oh my god you
can walk into the bush
it's the simpsons meme look i come out
and then go back and it's homer
homosexual
[Laughter]
when your child asks you how babies are
made
oh i don't think that's how they're made
no i'm hiding from that conversation
because it's uncomfortable
to talk about sexual things i get it i
get it
it's a meme template
oh okay it's fine it happens
all the time i yeah someone else go
first wait go first
be a stupid ghost on a stick thing it's
going to make me look like an idiot wait
you're the
one you're the horror game guy you go
why is wade
how wait mark how are you going to say
out loud wade you're the horror game
he's the horror game guy he's the horror
guy wade is best known for his settlers
of catan play through i think we all
know this
yes a terrifying game about the
realities of early civilization
politics oh yeah this was the light over
here so that's gonna be a good thing
that's a good sign good hooray this is
the right way
oh no it it this just forks back from
where oh
what you guys didn't see that no no i
didn't see anything mark what's going on
someone was just running that way oh
dead end
oh it's just a sign you google it it's
just a sign
it's just a dead end sign you silly
goose this is so bad
you're trying to go first for a bit no i
don't think so you're up buddy i don't
think so actually
we're pushing you off the floor okay all
right cool man you go
that's great hey you're the one who
works here staff shirt man what are you
as if you guys don't oh do i am i'm the
only one staff shirt
yeah you're the one wearing the staff
shirt normal humans
you guys just got gray hoodies i guess
yeah come on this well
hmm that's fine he's going he's going
the other way
he's not even going where was god i
wasn't me for once oh wait whoever is
running around the dark it's creepy how
about we just don't do that thanks
i agree take a break guys guys thank you
you're going the wrong
bush uh you kind of disappear from
reality for a second and it's kind of
feels like you're never going to find
your way out which is a little
terrifying
a little bit yeah a little bit okay am i
still leading is it still me
uh we can run my turn my turn okay yeah
your turn your turn your turn
all right that was a good stint that was
a good stint good ski this way
oh we're back that's great we're back on
the sign path baby keep going
if the ghost just on a stick makes me
jump again uh
clearly this is the way of course okay
it's misleading right
it's all ooh it's dark oh no just like a
heist with markiplier
people wanted to go down the dark path
instead of a [ __ ]
i'm fine it's fine uh-huh nice little
resting path again
this is lovely this is lovely all right
rotate where
you're standing alright i'll go all
right so this is a nice little straight
away
nothing oh it's so dark no it's a
mislead it's a misleading it'll get okay
look at this beautiful
they gotcha i was a little scared there
cuz it got real [ __ ] dark for a
minute there
another take a break another break this
is the most relaxing forgiving maze
it really is oh there's beers over here
glow sticks
there's a compass where the hell is
there a compass oh hey look a compass on
this wall
i got the glow sticks where's the
compass oh hey where someone should get
that
it's probably in a bush somewhere and
it's going to walk out bill
can you still grab a compass after i
grabbed it hello oh hey look
mark hi buddy sorry i got lost back
there glow sticks
wow that's interesting
so north is okay judging by the thing on
the horizon that's northeast so you see
the light on the horizon that's
northeast so
we've got that at least what are we
circumnavigating the globe
we might be who knows wait there's a
there's a note in this little secret
area i know if i was told off the end of
this restricted part but i need to know
what's through here the rumors i've
heard they must have some truth
if you're reading this i'm in here don't
board it back up joan well don't board
it back up
oh okay well i don't have the ability to
do that but i promise i won't hello
we're here we're here
i'm i'm not where are you mark's over
here he's trying to jump
so is that the only way we can go the
restricted part is this looks like it's
this is not a oh no this is a dead end
over here okay
no this pass is open down here where
down here
this way that's that's what he was
talking about that's what wait's talking
about oh okay
yeah yeah okay well i thought it was a
way that's the way we're supposed to go
that's the way we're supposed to guys i
found a secret damn it
hey look it's the
what boys hell just happened with our
audio oh no
um oh the cryptex
seitan guys i think santan has been here
the word on the statues deeper in the
maze it's
equivalent
[Music]
i'm sorry can i see is this the note you
were just trying no the one on the right
yeah aha
the word on the statue that even in the
maze
is eagles eagles
is go eagles go yeah
pretty sure that's it all right i guess
we gotta go down these stone pillars
i know i'm a big old wimp and i've been
jumping and everything but can i just
say
this is heck and spooky ah it's pretty
it's moderately spooky
i'm getting into it i don't know where
this is going even remotely but i wanna
i kind of wanna see yeah did you guys
read this note the one that says
the shifting stone oh yeah yeah oh yeah
what's it say
uh ha got it i had to shift some stones
plates further into
this thing man i should write down every
thought i have and just leave them
places and see if they help people on
their journey
if i'm ever in a situation of dire
distress and danger i'm just going to
start jotting little things down like
oh hey cool he's he's going he's leaving
right yeah that's fine
how did he come out of this how did he
what was he doing in here ah look man
who knows and who cares i want to know
again yeah yeah mm-hmm getting real
close again
getting real honest
it wasn't moving what do you mean it was
charging back what are you talking about
it disappeared no it didn't mark and i
didn't see anything
oh oh now it's okay
are things just very separate i'm still
not
seeing it i didn't see anything weird
well
i want to go first i don't want to be
left out
okay scoob you want a scooby snack
yeah okay they're laughing at your
children over there having an
awesome time look at this cool 1940s
tricycle
drop the glow stick on this
good idea so wait does that mean we're
heading north east right now and this
is how do you read a company red points
north
so the direction you're going is
relative to that
glow glow hey guys your glow sticks bob
we lost you uh mark's
having some glow sticks guys i think i
found the party
hello oh okay good
oh that's not a good noise that's not a
party
it needs more candles it's the it's the
party oh you can pick up the skulls
neat you can't oh you can yeah sure
someone has removed all the teeth yep
surely this isn't real
mine is having an edm dance party it's
freaking jamming out over here
how do you throw the glow stick you left
click
hello man
we're definitely gonna know where we was
hello
and where we didn't was and where these
skulls are at
dude i got it are you just going mark
are you just progressing right yeah man
what are you guys doing waiting around
twiddling your dogs i didn't realize we
picked up such an unlimited
supply of glow sticks i got the
multi-pack quite the pile
yeah bone
[Music]
globo i wonder what or who
this belongs to glow this is
glow my boy i'm listening to officer
frank mill
oh my boy roberts i'm catching up
glow glow glow i have no idea what that
tastes like
i said do you guys know my boy here was
glow
somebody's having a bad day down here
reminder to self give them space
my boy hello give my boy space my boy
glow oh the music yeah creepy murder
music yeah what's the second ism
my boy i love this song
can't believe it your boy roberts yeah
my boy roberts
love this song now what the what's the
mechanism it's referencing
three statues ahead have letters which
form the cryptex code they are not busts
oh my boy never knew a bust
from a statue guy he's tweaking pretty
bad i thought he was looking right at me
but i just froze up and he wandered away
note to self call someone to get this
guy when i'm out
i wonder what they mean by froze up and
he wandered away
are people interacting with other
people's notes that are everyone [ __ ]
with their paper and their
somebody saw what we saw at the
beginning of this area and had the exact
thought that i did and they were like i
better write this down
everyone wait hold on before you cross
this do you guys hear that
the wind whipping oh no
no okay i thought i was crazy uh but why
don't you go first then
okay your boy might be down there my boy
roberts your boy roberts well
there's a there's a hello sir or madam
oh wait wait wait wait wait
whoosh do you hear the whispering
uh oh i was that thing's looking and
also has
hey oh you want a glow stick buddy is
there glow sticks
what is it what is it about what are you
oh it's got stuff on them
yeah turn off your lights it says
what is that sound it's probably nothing
um what are we supposed to take from
that
awful chest writing
turn your lights off what's wrong with
you i don't know i can't see it in fact
my lights off it closed i gotta know
where it is before we do it oh
yeah i agree it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's going by
okay we're probably fine probably fine
yeah probably i don't know if we need to
adapt to that statue it seems it doesn't
seem very helpful yeah it said it's
not the bus that's what it said not the
busts that's what it was
all right well they don't let us astray
that's my bad yeah my boy ain't in a
bust
that's for sure it's more of an ass man
well i don't know my boy's a bit too
young
to determine that but one can only hope
as a proud papa you know what i mean you
know what i'm talking about
you know uh god i missed my i certainly
do
robert father yeah robert's other father
you understand don't you
oh goodness i oh look how narrow it gets
this is cool
i think this is please i hope there's
one of our glowing zombie friends
somewhere
echo i need to remember that
[Music]
i'm going to remember this i'm going to
remember
do you know what drives the pirate ship
yeah do you know what detectives look
for
oh [ __ ] okay that wasn't funny my joke
wasn't funny i'm
[Laughter]
you have sorry been rejected by the game
symbols
oh ground symbol jordan 23
heart this mechanism looks old i doubt
johnny said apparently
looks like the tiles might activate oh
light them all up we just need to light
them all
up oh it's like a pattern okay yeah
you're good at these things
let me see mark yeah you're good at
these things you just do it that's all
right i mean i am good at these things
wait why'd that one too yeah yeah yeah
you're good at these you're good
i mean i am kind of i'd like to think so
wait wait wait i have it oh you got it
uh
no that didn't light up what i thought
it was i got it i got oh who turned that
one off over there god damn it i
almost i had it by one um if i hit that
one wait i think i got it
this and then yeah you're in a position
where you can do it there we go
we all did it we did it we did it we did
it is this where we need to go yeah my
boy i smell them
that's his name that's what i call him
my boy
uh no why why is the gate locked now
behind us then
no i think that's just another way
around that we've been i swear i saw you
guys see that we got
locked in here did you no no i don't
know what i think did i just see
what did you do what did you just see a
man's running
i saw a man running before but earlier i
saw that
it's getting darker and darker with no
light
we got it we got lights plus we got
glows what are you doing oh you missed
it we're back oh
oh wow equals [ __ ] you got you fixed
that one i
i messed it up okay so i think what we
have to do is we got to split up because
there's no way we can cover all this
ground ourselves
what we're gonna split up no i don't i'm
going in no
my boy but my
ball did we go back in the same hole i
think so yeah
oh it's so dark there's something that
we do
wait i don't know where there's
different paths well we'll find them
well you know there's glow sticks
everywhere we have been yeah and where
mark is
so just go where there ain't glow sticks
yeah it's silly
it's really dark you know
thankfully we have all these glow sticks
to follow okay we've been down there
i haven't been down i'm going down this
one i don't know what one he was
referring to do you bob
i'm going down a path oh he's down there
i just saw him he's down that way
yep i'll find some following until we
find another branching off pack
yeah well these are all
here's it here's a new path wait there's
a path here for you
you want to go right or left x's
x's greens magazines z's
two packs
oh oh you're right
there's a whole bunch of pads down my
path go down that bath
ah you all right bob i think i'm dead
oh no that's not good i i think i'm dead
that's not good that's not one of you
guys oh that's not one of you what
happened to you bob oh i'm not throwing
my glow sticks
oh uh consumed by a terror monster
and where was that in a between some
ferns what the hell kind of question is
that so many glow sticks down
yeah is that helpful i feel like that's
helpful oh there's another one
oh i'm dead again oh wait are you being
murdered over and over again
apparently yes yeah well i got xcs i
don't know how many parts
well you're there oh okay
ah we're fine all right i think i'm
being an idiot the solution is to stop
moving right
i don't know i was backing away and i
stopped being angry at me
so oh god sticks down my path now
well i don't think we're ever going to
get out of here
oh god i can't see [ __ ] no it's still
there
oh don't come down here bob
did it come after you i don't know what
it's doing
well let's see what death is like huh oh
hey i found a thing
you get to really see what they look
like who are these statues look like one
said miles
fur same last name as the lady painted
all the planted all the trees miles fur
i found a creepy death oh i know i know
i don't know that's all of them right
xcs ino was it six things we needed
or nine things we needed oh hi hey
okay i don't know why you know
i'm trying to avoid uh glow sticks but
i'm finding
hey whoa it's wade you're fine you're
not at all going to kill me
not intentionally there's the bad guy
somewhere around here be careful
yeah watch out uh there's something bad
down that way it looks like
that's him he's the one yeah he's hi
don't go
hey mark okay what's wrong we're left
there why no
wait wait don't we have to wait did we
go out here to get to the
thingy the codex thingy well i don't
know the barn was back here is it
behind the barn i don't remember
remember i thought we'd get it after the
barn
this guides us right oh this isn't no it
doesn't
guide us this is the respawn yeah no
it was past this wasn't it oh we can't
go back this way anyway it's closed off
so you got to go forward
lead the way i think not moving is the
solution i've been
freaked out and i've run it it really
was my mistake
it almost passed me by i was in the
bushes by it and it almost
got by me so you got ino
we need no sex equinox
ino is what i got i got xcs
how do we know what order it goes in
we'll find out well i guess i
know would be the middle and xces would
be the end right no you look at the
piece of paper that had
part of it but it had the beginning and
the ends so you would know
there's no word that uses those letters
that i know
that is a word so i figured it out guys
really helping is there is it
equinox yes like the gym
i like the gym yeah yeah yeah yeah mark
you run like just such a couch potato
thank you oh i think i know's the middle
i'll do the eye
i'll just watch you guys got this man
but there's so many letters you could
help
you could help you could help look i'm
making i'm putting glow sticks down
is this not helpful i got it
you done yeah are you not entertained
i'm not entertained
man we could have guessed that all right
we did it oh
oh oh oh oh interesting
all right goodbye we're leaving now to
safety forever
sure i think so my boy don't forget to
glow your surroundings my dudes
my boy you in here roberts my boy
i haven't seen you oh i want one of
these
guys i got a lure well i gotta learn
this will help us find our way
we got a lurp and a glow this is what
does this say
gate lock behind me right radio is not
working either gonna move further into
the maze
i like that the music is all like uh
rejects from
uh that really popular netflix show with
the underworld what's that called
stranger things oh yeah
stranger strangers danger yeah that's
the one guys guys look in the
in the building in the window oh damn it
oh
whatever hang on okay
[Music]
hello oh my god there's two people
oh are we being zombies or something
i was just gonna scare them all right i
get it
yeah whatever i thought i thought we
were doing a bit well we're not anymore
well don't be a bad bad
sport don't do that i just said don't do
that i'm running into the woodsticks
i'm abandoning the way there's something
behind the gates i can hear it breathing
i don't believe it i don't know if the
lurp is an upgrade i feel like it mostly
shines a light into my own stupid face
yeah did you guys read the note yeah i
read the note there's something behind
the game
what's it say there's something
something markiplier
oh somebody oh
i hear that lately so what do we do in
this game
i don't know man no i don't know
yeah i really don't know if the lamp's
an upgrade i agree empty still requires
five seals okay i found it
okay oh we need to get the we need to
get the thingos hey there's a tape guys
there's a tape guys here officer frank
miller here
officer how's your boy
this open space
my god tells me robert will be in there
now how can i get this damn thing open
seems like there's something in here oh
oh my god oh there we go
that's a missed [ __ ] right there yeah
oh i don't over here yeah over here
what's the note say
do anyone else find
this lantern do not help this lantern
help none
switching up i agree wade and i had that
discussion
long ago and have since already thusly
switched all right well you know
sometimes i gotta feel a doubt verily
good sir
oh my god yeah i'm left i'm going on my
own i guess
yeah goodbye oh do you hear me glow
hello boys are the stonks rising hello
the fire is rising oh i hear that is
there some sort of
airplane i don't think there's an
airplane
what are you i don't know
oh it found me even though ah
[Music]
bad things are happening to weak
if you come across the fellow who's
breathing whose mouth breathing quite
heavily
careful there are so many paths
everywhere like
watch out yeah i think we need to lay
down gloves
damn it i tried to agree with
that wait you okay it was a ghost
[ __ ] paddle oh well that means it's
probably near you merc
oh no wait no that's not good i'm laying
down all the glow sticks i can i still
haven't looped back
oh where where am i where am i i found a
greenhouse
oh i see something oh [ __ ]
how many notes lost two batches of cb
don't use yellow or blue
damn vines pesticides what
what is any of this what the [ __ ] i
agree with that sentiment someone just
cast a spell to put vines in my path i
can't go through them
i found a puzzle with some arrows in it
i'll probably be able to solve this on
my own all right
wait wait you're not supposed to come
over here ooh
no the thing no what it's yelling
something is yelling
oh jesus christ come on
did it get you yeah i've got some kind
of like chemical
thing i don't know i'm just going to
guess
screw it i can't even go there oh god no
no don't worry wait you get to respawn
at the bar and it's fine
well here's a gate with no freaking
things down it
oh you're right mark
guys i
oh the lights in the playground are off
now
i got i did the puzzle i i did it i
guess here we go
it's a greenhouse puzzle it was just a
simon says he kind of thing i gotta i
gotta
go i gotta seal oh you're dead oh
are you dead you better be dead why not
again
well i'm glad it's not just me guys i
got i got a crest
what is that sound it's fine it's fine
this is fine i gotta crush don't worry
about it
what is that what is that
dude everything is really looking up for
me right now hello
i'm not responding wow am i
oh there's a response i'm gonna use the
restroom i gotta pee so bad i'll be
right back
all right bye i'm gonna go put this
thing in the oh no am i here again
no not like this bob you're not going to
believe this
wade went afk standing in the doorway to
the respawn cabin i can't get out
no it's literally blocking me
god damn you wait what have you done
well i guess i'll just chill in here
have fun bob
maybe i'll go to the bathroom too maybe
i'll take a potty break i guess
i'm back how's it going fun
i'm trapped at a puzzle i'm never gonna
be able to figure out
oh bob how do i find
and an [ __ ] keeps coming up and
making screechy sounds behind me
i'm back oh there's a new path open
is there no if you guys find the
greenhouse
that's no i've already taken care of it
if you find the kid's playground i have
the
thing that was over there i have the the
thing wait
that's just down here to the right i had
a chemical that could break down
vines but apparently it's not active
here so that's stupid
oh wait this is a dead end what the hell
i just can't this literally just opened
up in front of me it's a dead end it's
just a period it's a dead end just got
here it's a dead end wade i'm sticking
with you old buddy so i don't get lost
again
buddy it's a dead end but you and me
we're gonna solve this uh-huh yeah
uh-huh bob did you find a sigil
i have one sigil and i'm doing a puzzle
for a second one right now i have one
sigil wade how many sigils did you get
zero this is a dead end wade there's a
dead end i don't understand what
information i'm not gathering that will
make this make sense
i'm so confused what is the rumble oh
don't like that
i'm an idiot i'm some kind of idiot god
dang it
what does it mean when there's rumbling
everywhere around you all at once
good only good what happened wait did
you get the rumbling
ah it's time to begin oh i see something
huge oh what is that
are we winning at this game yet what is
that
[Music]
oh it's a statue oh my god oh it's a
statue
mark where are you need to find your
best buddy friend i was around nearby i
don't know can you hear my in-game voice
yeah but yeah no i gotta go back toward
the death creature
all right
[Music]
uh i don't know man i i don't know i'm
buy two statues of some assless i mean
pantsless ass men ass you're still
throwing
ah
[Applause]
don't be dead in don't be dead in don't
be a dead end don't be a dead end
running away from that i'm getting fined
i got fined
you got vine man that sucks that sucks
oh i [ __ ] two statues yeah keep going
from there
you should see my glowies do you see my
oh hi okay
there you are bob hi hey so you could
hear
all of our screams so you could you were
you were just ignoring us
what am i gonna do i'm trying solving
stupid goddamn puzzles
son of a [ __ ] what is the problem i see
glowy's
oh so this one this one is first
and then this one is second okay and
then this one is third
okay and i have figured this all out
purely by guessing and i can't find any
meaningful information anywhere on how
any of this is supposed to work
start here the next one is to the right
getting the order wrong resets it okay
so i think it's just
it's just got to be guessing right well
i haven't found the fourth one yet so i
have no idea
it's this one i guess okay this is the
fourth one
most of these things won't turn but one
of them is lit up uh is
is why you did that
i was trying to pick up the notes i
think i actually bumped here don't
touch it where are more puzzles
there's five total so yeah we have four
sigils
i have one i have one on me this one
will have one in it presumably
all right okay that'll count as my one
one
i'm gonna backtrack i think there was
another path off of the statues
to go okay okay okay 50 50 chance here
which one is it which one is it
i believe in you i guessed wrong god
damn it oh that's what that noise was
okay
i'm just i'm not yours no yeah don't
touch it i think i have the solution i
think i got it
stacey1 frickin god damn it i'm fine
yeah i'm fine hell yes nicely done
nicely done you take your take your
schedule that you earned
thank you thank you oh all right oh you
have a sigil i think mark what you got
uh i found a pile of bones okay
they look pretty fresh um i don't think
it's my boy looks like an adult skeleton
so i think we're good
oh i found a whole nother section over
here that's opened up so i think that uh
oh no yeah so how do we get back to you
then i guess this way by the statues
again
i don't know it's going to be tough
because i've been laying down glowsticks
so you'd have to follow a path that
follows the glow sticks and this might
be mark's pile of bones
you find that with the maze book that
didn't help the person
yeah yeah so okay so we're hot on we're
hot on mark's trail
and then left oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] god you guys good
yeah it's fine oh i found something hey
cool
playground wait wait where's the um
where's the thing we can stick the
signals in do you think this is
where'd you go is this the new one no
that's where i just came from that's
where i just came out of
okay i'm not sure where mark's new path
is
i i'm at a playground i don't like it
here
i got the one from the playground i got
them from the playground that's not a
why isn't it
music's kicking up well there's glow
sticks down that path
maybe this was close music's kicking up
i don't see glow sticks down here you
see glow sticks down here
music's gonna get up it's fine you're
fine yeah you're
you're following a bunch of glow sticks
bob i don't see him
oh okay i'm probably dead guys i'll see
you around hey can you get my will to
the nearest
lawyer please for me that'd be great oh
hey
hey guys i died i know you care hey i
found the playground
i died near there so where'd you where'd
you oh
yeah that are you oh i think i'm dead
now
yeah okay we got
three of the five sigils we just need
two more oh you put them in there yeah i
think i put them in for you guys so
no no no no no no no no no no no
mark how did you get there uh if you go
to the respawn house and you just follow
the straight path you don't go through
any of the gates you'll get there
i think i put yours you guys as in so i
think i got those in
oh maybe found something maybe have
something all right here we go
here we go i found the place oh we do
indeed have three out of the five
yes some weird altar thing but doesn't
look like it has anything on it
i'm gonna go back to my murder path i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go down this
apparently new one maybe okay okay
maybe i'll see one of you guys before i
see a monster what if i'm the monster
get it yeah because that's a terrible
song
yeah hey i found the fourth and fifth
sigils sitting on a table with a side
that says here
take them
i think i hear whatever you're
encountering okay wow
is that a real burpee bad guy i hate
where i
am right now i describe them as burpish
uh well not burpee uh just
real happy really happy oh big
big smile mouth man
god damn it more yeah what's up
you're right yeah oh i think i found the
altar that you found mark
yeah i don't know it's just a tree with
candles yeah i've been there
i've been there yeah that's a there's a
guy here yeah because i think
oh what the hell
who's being chased someone's being
chased
[Music]
i just met i just saw a guy and ran i
found
another sigil so we just need one more
hell yeah folks eventually disappeared i
think
they do yeah i think they do oh god i'm
never gonna know where the last one is
i found a birthday party
yeah that birthday party yeah uh-huh
okay i found the birth
wow what a joyous occasion the
birthday party is so i see why you liked
it so much mark i'm glad that i'm here
oh where am i now oh interesting i found
a
field there's a tractor here that sounds
new
that sounds new that is it is kind of
new okay is that from bob's puzzle mark
can you guide me for me
i have no idea okay i'm gonna leave
this now and never
ever never just never oh oh she's coming
for me
oh no hey i might be dead soon it's okay
though
cool man hey i found a picnic table with
the phones on it
yeah is that bad yeah keep going from
there follow my lamps because
i found this farm and i think the last
sigil has got to be here
i just got blinded in somewhere i don't
i don't know never mind
i got i got the last sigil we're good
guys okay
all right cool good we can go home i'm
positive about your accomplishments can
i just say thank you yeah i found the
greenhouse
how do i get to a place i want to be
from anything else
wait come on pull your weight around
here you got to find some you really got
a health weight you got to contribute
yeah contribute weight you gotta
contribute please wait please
contribute yes oh no this claustrophobia
nightmare never ends
oh my god it has to someday
all right yeah the ruins get depo
okay no that's where you want to be
that's where you want to be yeah
uh oh what's the song what's that about
what happened
wade put the sigils in the thingy oh he
he took our accomplishments
yeah yes he did i just charged [ __ ] did
i just go in a circle
said both of us i only had one i think i
just dead ass what in a circle oh i want
to be out i want to be out oh hey
lady lady lady lady lady
lady kill me
all right i'm dead okay i'm literally
trying to get this guy to kill me and
he's not
okay there we go i don't know where you
guys are i'm over here you guys need to
get over here
i will grab you by your scrote
uh okay a little violet not
nicely hey come on bob go easy he found
some right wait you found some sigils
yeah you
you found some sigils on your own right
i took one from bob and i played sure
sure two that were not mine to play you
stole
one from bob and then you so you didn't
find any ceiling if you didn't have like
the
patent out um it was my original idea
according to
history so okay that makes sense
according to the american
patent system that makes sense which is
the best patent system in the world
well it's the one we got here in
american hedge maze hey
okay you were the first one to arrive at
the amazing race congratulations i saw a
name tag in the distance
hey man we are horrible litterers the
chemicals in these glow sticks are going
to wreak havoc on the environment they
eventually run out
yeah i'm pretty sure these are
biodegradable okay yeah yeah
okay of course of of course of course
dude look at all those cool schedules
that we've mostly found
yeah are we free so we're done then
right yeah we're free right
check point save oh wow oh for the love
of god i didn't know i was playing a
puzzle game
well i guess we just wander into the
woods and die then
sounds good to me there's a bonfire we
can throw ourselves into oh house oh we
get to go home
this is a lot more open i don't know if
that's good or bad for us
it's like oh it's nice in here there's a
toilet
it was done for when i was warming up
near the bonfire but that thing
just ignored me like i wasn't even there
if you're reading this stay near fire or
indoors
right okay let's stay indoors then
that's gonna have to be it for me
yeah should we call it here i think so
yes interesting game
more wandering than i would prefer but
not bad
kind of scary with the ghost on the
sticks though right
[Music]